last nine shot from the fields
[Music]
chris paul left open has plenty of time
three-pointer
that's good going forward as they like
to say
[Applause]
chris paul one-on-one with cousins shot
clock at seven
paul a little shake and make drives past
him left-handed lay-up it's good
[Applause]
ball with four to shoot paul puts up a
three putts it in
cousins misses the free throw that foul
on eighteen was his second
14 point lead then it's gone by here in
the fourth paul to the basket
lays it up and in
paul gets inside looks back nobody near
him
hits the jumper 26 for paul in the lead
up to 18.
and then snakes behind the backboard
fatum and cousins have a
miscommunication
and he gets the practice shot the suns
are rolling
up 20.
26.6 assists for chris paul
there's the screen set by ayton paul
pull up jumper
punch it in chris paul does it again
chris paul responded here
gets right to his spot little fade
mid-ranger
[Applause]
terence man pokes it into the backcourt
[Applause]
paul step back three-punter punch it in
and
upset it what happened on the last play
paul george took him down one-on-one
returns the favor cp three
and the foul big-time effort by chris
paul sensing the ability the opportunity
eight assists three rebounds couple of
steals
and a 21 point lead for his sons paul
gets inside flips it up and
chris paul dominating right now eight to
shoot for chris paul
devin book is at half court talking to
the fans paul for three puts it in
[Music]
118 and 92 the sons have blown it open
we've seen this movie before we have an
issue on the court right now between
both teams but chris paul
beverly and chris paul that's never
happened before a team making the finals
after missing the playoffs
for 10 years or more paul putting on the
finishing touches
what a performance from chris paul